in addition to l2 regularization and
drop our regularization their few other
techniques for reducing over sitting in
your neural network let's take a look
let's say you're fitting a CAD
classifier if you are overfitting
getting more training data can help but
getting more training data can be
expensive and sometimes just can't get
more data but what you can do is augment
your training set by taking an image
like this and for example flipping
horizontally and adding that also to
training set so now instead of just this
one example when your training set you
can add this to your training example so
by flipping your images horizontally you
could you know really double the size
your training set because your training
set is now a bit redundant this isn't as
good as if you had collected an
additional M set of brand new
independent examples but you could do
this without needing to pay the expense
of going out to take me click more
pictures of cats and then other than
surfing horizontally you can also take
random props of the image so here we've
rotated and so a randomly zoom into the
invention this pool looks like a tag but
so by taking random distortions and
transformations in the image you can
augment your data set and make
additional fake training examples again
these extra fake training examples they
don't add as much information as you
were to go on and get a brand new
independent example of a cat but because
you could do this you know almost a free
other than for some computational cost
or this can be an inexpensive way to
give your data this can be an
inexpensive way to give your algorithm
more data and therefore no sort of
regular eyes it and reduce all the 15
and by synthesizing examples like this
what you're really telling your
algorithm is that is something that's a
cat then slipping on horizontally is
still account notice eyes inserted
vertically because maybe we don't want
upside-down cats right and then also
maybe randomly zooming and are the
inventions pretty slow account for
optical character recognition you can
also open your data set by take a digit
and imposing random rotations and
distortions to
so if you add these things to your
training set you know these are also
still digit fours for illustration I
applied a very strong distortion so this
looks very way before in practice you
don't need to distort the for quite as
aggressively but just a more subtle
distortion than what I'm showing here to
make this example clearer for you right
but the most subtle distortion is
usually used in practice because this
looks like really warp divorce so data
augmentation can be used as
regularization techniques and effects
similar to regularization there's one
other technique that is often used
called early stopping so what you're
going to do is as you run gradient
descent you're going to plot your either
training error or your zero one
classification error on the training set
or just plot the cost function J
optimizing and that should decrease
monotonically like so all right because
as you train hopefully you're trading
around your cost function J chikki
please so what's early stopping what you
do is you plot this and you'll also plot
your def set error and again this could
be a classification error and
development variable something like the
cost function like the logistic loss of
the log loss of evaluation or
death's-head now once you find is that
your death set error will usually go
down for a while and then it will
increase from there
so what early stopping does is you say
well it looks like your new network is
doing best around that elevation so
we're just going to stop training on
your network halfway and you'll take one
of the value achieved this dead set
error so why does this work well when
you haven't run many iterations for your
neural network yet your parameters W
will be close to zero because you know
with random initialization you probably
initialize W to small random values so
before you train for a long time W is
still quite small and that's the
integrate as you train W get bigger and
bigger and bigger and so here maybe you
have a much larger value of the
parameters W for your neural network so
what early stopping does is by stopping
halfway you have only a you know mid
size right
w I'm so similar to l2 regularization by
picking a new network was smaller norm
for your parameters W hopefully your new
network is overfitting less and the term
early stopping refers to the fact that
you're just stopping the training of
your new network early I sometimes use
early stopping when training on your
network but it does have one downside
let me explain
I think the machine learning process as
comprising several different steps one
is that you want an algorithm so
optimize the cost function J and we have
various tools to do that you know such
as gradient descent and then we'll talk
later about other algorithms like
momentum and algorithm and rmsprop and
atom and so on but then after optimizing
the cost function J as you also wanted
to not over fit and we have some tools
to do that such as your regularization
getting more data and so on now in
machine learning we already have so many
hyper parameters to search over is
already very complicated to choose among
the space of possible algorithms and so
I find machine learning easier to think
about when you have one set of tools for
optimizing the cost function J and when
you're focusing on authorizing the cost
function J all you care about is finding
W and B so that J of W B is as small as
possible you just don't think about
anything else other than producing this
and then it's completely separate tasks
to not overstate in other words to
reduce the Arians
and when you're doing that you have a
second set of tools of doing it and this
principle is sometimes called
orthogonalization and this is idea that
you want to think about one task at a
time
I'll see you more about also
organization in a later video so if you
don't fully get the concept yet don't
worry about it but to me the main
downside is early swapping is that this
couples these two toss so you no longer
can work on these two problems
independently because by stopping
gradient descent early you're sort of
breaking whatever you're doing to
optimize the cost function J because now
you're not doing
a jar reducing the cost function genius
or not done that that well and then
you're also simultaneously trying to not
overstate so instead of using different
tools to solve the two problems you're
using one two they kind of mix us the
two and this just makes the set of
things you could try a more complicated
to think about rather than you think
early stopping one alternative is just
use l2 regularization then you can just
train the neural network as long as
possible
I find it this makes the search space of
type of parameters easier to decompose
and each of the search over but the
downside of this though is that you
might have to try a lot of values of the
regularization parameter lambda and so
this makes searching over many values of
lambda more computationally expensive
and the real advantage of early stopping
is that running the gradient descent
process just once you get to try out
values of small W midsize W at large W
without needing to try a lot of values
of the regularization LT regularization
hybrid parameter lambda um if this
concept doesn't completely make sense
yet don't worry about it we'll talk
about orthogonalization in greater
detail in the later video I think this
would make a bit more sense this
presence disadvantages many people do
use it I personally prefer to just use
l2 regularization and try different
values of lambda that's assuming you can
afford a computation to do so but early
stopping does let you get a similar
effect without needing to explicitly try
lots of different values of lambda so
you've now seen how to use data
augmentation as well as if you wish
early stopping in order to reduce
variance and prevent overfitting is in
your network next let's talk about some
techniques for such an optimization
problem to make your training go quickly